perched on the edge of antarctica sits a
tiny ukrainian outpost
this is the vernatsky research center
where penguins frolic among the ice
flows
and where a small team of ukrainian
scientists has been trapped helplessly
watching the invasion of their country
14 000 kilometers away information about
missile strikes and other cities shocked
all of us
it's impossible to describe the feeling
of helplessness in this situation each
of us spent the first week of the world
without sleep the researchers were
supposed to end their year-long
expedition in february but war left them
frozen in place at the bottom of the
world
their only link to home has been
satellite internet it's slow and often
stops working
what they do know is their villages and
cities are being bombed their families
and friends are in danger we all felt
the mix of emotions like anger
despair
helplessness
frustration at a time like this the
scientists would all rather be back in
ukraine
as the situation has grown more dire
they've turned from research to outreach
on youtube the team appealed to their
fellow russian scientists to speak out
against the invasion and they unfurled
the blue and yellow flag of ukraine in
the snow with a message of solidarity
our hearts are full of pain from what is
happening in our homeland
isolation and desperation have taken a
physical toll according to the
expedition's doctor we are quite
stressed and anxious it led
to the blood pressure spikes
and insomnia
relief finally came this week when a
replacement team arrived along with a
ship to take the scientists home
they still don't know how long the
journey will take or what awaits them
i've come to tell us with the fact that
my life will never be the same
it seems
that the war will be not ended quickly
after war followed them to the most
isolated place on the planet they know
the ukraine they return to will be
vastly different from the country they
left more than a year ago
jackson proskow global news